ahora que podemos hacer racing en 2d
podemos regresar por fin al problema que
realmente queremos resolver plate racing
en 3-d en particular necesitaremos hacer
rock racing para planos bidimensionales
casas y finalmente personajes
un personaje como carne es una forma
compleja pero como comentamos en la
lección de modelado de personajes él
puede desglosarse en una multitud de
pequeños cuadriláteros
es decir polígonos de cuatro lados
y cada cuadrilátero puede convertirse en
dos triángulos agregando un borde que
conecte puntos diagonales eso nos lleva
a preguntarnos cómo se intersecta un
rayo con un triángulo resulta que ese es
uno de los cálculos más fundamentales
que realiza un rey fleischer
esta es una escena que consta de un solo
triángulo
nuestras verdaderas escenas contienen
millones de triángulos pero una vez que
sabemos cómo se intersecta un solo
triángulo nuestro rey fraser simplemente
sigue haciendo eso una y otra vez
ahora no sé tú pero yo no quiero hacer
lo mismo una y otra vez así que es bueno
saber que contamos con computadoras que
nos ayudan y no se cansan
al igual que lo hacemos al trabajar en
dos dimensiones empezamos por establecer
un sistema de coordenadas pero esta vez
hay tres direcciones x que iceta
como lo explicamos antes seleccionamos
una posición de cámara
llamémosla ce y una dirección de
visualización
y construimos un plano de visión
perpendicular a la dirección de
visualización aquí es donde se formará
nuestra imagen
seleccionemos un píxel p en el plano de
visión y construyamos una representación
paramétrica del rayo
cp
como rt es igual a 1
de porsche
más deporte
esta es la misma ecuación que vimos en
2d
pero ahora representa tres ecuaciones
separadas una para las coordenadas x una
para las coordenadas y otra para las
coordenadas z
recuerda que en el vídeo anterior vimos
que en dos dimensiones cada una de las
líneas puede escribirse en forma
implícita como a x más bella más c es
igual a 0
esto es muy similar a la ecuación de un
plano
y cada triángulo se sitúa en un plano
la ecuación para un plano puede
escribirse en forma implícita como x más
bella más ez más d es igual a cero
el punto de intersección y que buscamos
está en el plano del triángulo
lo que significa que a por y sube x más
ve por y subió más por y sub zeta
+ d es igual a 0
donde hizo vx y subió a z son las
coordenadas de iu y también está en el
rayo lo que significa que hay un valor
de t de nuevo llamémosle t asterisco tal
que y es igual a rd t asterisco
lo que equivale a 1 - de asterisco por
ser más te asterisco por p
que realmente son las tres ecuaciones
que se muestran aquí una para x una para
allá y una para zeta
ahora tenemos cuatro ecuaciones y cuatro
incógnitas
para resolver este sistema de ecuaciones
podemos seguir la receta de 2d y
sustituir las últimas tres ecuaciones en
la primera
esto nos da una ecuación con una sola
incógnita de asterisco y aunque cuando
introducimos todas estas sustituciones
se vea un tanto aterrorizante recuerda
no es tan terrible
solo estamos introduciendo el valor de
una ecuación en otra
resuelve esto párate asterisco luego
sustituye de regreso en las ecuaciones
del rayo para obtener y sube x y sub sub
zeta ahora entiendo que hemos avanzado
algo rápido pero el siguiente ejercicio
te permitirá practicar el cálculo de
puntos de intersección por ti mismo